you're going on to this to this great
movie career but then people wonder will
somewhere down the line you're so young
other other things you might try or the
other things you're thinking about like
they're sort of outside the pale oh yeah
I start I've started studying
criminology which I'm really excited
about criminal or terminology yeah yeah
like seriously you want to study ecology
for real yeah I go III I'm working on a
course and I'm taking assignments and I
mean I'm only in like unit two right now
so I'm very early on but I'm not I solve
crimes I wanna I want to be a detective
that is Spencer I'm you know first of
all I think I would be so wait now take
me through this first of all how are you
preparing you're taking courses have you
visited any crime scenes is that the
kind of thing you want to do I have I
have this great cop friend Jerry he's my
driver in New York but he's told me that
he would take me to see an autopsy do
you want to see an autopsy yeah but like
it's it's all part of the job you know I
got to get used to it yeah okay that's
fat first of all it's so different from
what I would think that you might want
to do that's just so left-field to me
have you always been interested in
crimes and solving crimes a lot of
crimes I'm obsessed with them I watch
crime shows religiously because all I do
i watch Forensic Files if I start
watching or these show Forensic Files
they'll show eight hundred in a row yeah
if I start watching it my family doesn't
see me anymore you know I just want to
check into a hotel and watch a whole
bunch of them what about do you watch
like prison shows yeah I thought I would
wouldn't you love to spend a day in
prison I'm with you on the autopsy now
No
I think they lit in the shower first of
all when you're visiting hi I'm here in
Princeton everybody hope you follow up
on that that would be really thank you
I'll let you know yeah well I'm sure
I'll read about it
keep tracks real low-key having you
there is that from the investigation at
all shape shift a little more yeah you
can show up that claim right show up a
puffing on a Python say what did you or
what's what's going on please yo who's
that lacks accent what's come on she I
wasn't in Game of Thrones you're
thinking of someone else
see